do you know a single person who would
treat their business the way that people
treat their relationships the business
would be dead love is not a permanent
state of enthusiasm that just exists why
you shouting at
me stare Parell the most famous
relationship therapist on the planet PA
CER bestselling author and she had one
of the most weird head talks of all time
in order to want sex it needs to be
worth wanting so when women don't want
sex is it really that they have less
desire or is it that they don't have
desire for the sex they have and this
fear of rejection is one of the most
important emotional vulnerabilities for
many men it's part of what is so
alluring and porn which takes care of
three major dilemas around sex the first
one is and this leads to lying and
cheating I want to know how I avoid
getting to that place people end up in a
rut because they're so lazy so
complacent if you give the best of
yourself at work and then you bring the
leftovers home taking out your phone and
not present slowly you relationship
degrades because the more he refuses to
be present the more alone she feels and
the more alone she feels the more she
tests him to see if you're really not
there for me it's a figure eight Loop
and whether it's money kids sex every
topic could become part of the loop but
the quality of your life is determined
by the quality of your relationships
without it we die what do we do about it
though well this is one of the best
things I can offer to people is that
every now and then I meet someone on
this podcast that I classify as a wizard
or witch and I say that because the
impact they have on me is so
profound so lifechanging so pivoting in
terms of what I thought I
knew that I look at them like a witch or
a wizard I just think how does this
person seem to just know everything
Esther Pella is one of those people
she's magic what she knows about
relationships love sex and everything in
between will both blow your mind inspire
you and unlock a bunch of answers that I
think the vast majority of us are
currently looking for I've spent 10
years thinking that relationships are
slightly confusing they're a bit of a
black box I've wondered why some people
are needy and others are anxious in
relationships why does some people in
relationships run away and others chase
them all of these answers these black
boxes as it relates to relationships
love and sex Esther has the answer too
and I can't wait for you to listen to
this episode it might just change your
life and before this episode begins one
favor to ask you you probably know what
this favor is if you listen to this
podcast frequently if you hit the
Subscribe button on this podcast which
roughly 58% of you have then I promise
you we will do everything in our power
to make this show better and better for
you that's the only favor I'll ever ask
you do we have a deal thank
[Music]
you
Esther what is the mission you're on you
know we spoke before we started
recording about a plethora of different
subjects that you're innately curious
about if you were to summarize all of
those subjects what is EST perel's
Mission the quality of your life is
determined by the quality of your
relationships and relationships are
often not taken very seriously as a
subject of inquiry
right because um in various worlds it
has a certain attitude right so in the
easiest one would be in the business
World relationships have usually been
seen as soft skills fluff feminine
skills or feminine concerns feminine
concerns you can always hold in high
regard but then disregard in reality
I think that for so long relationships
were
structured organized through social
order religion communal structures and
so people didn't really have to think
about them so much they were very very
codified they still are codified in most
parts of the world but in our Western
world where we have dismantled all the
structures that used to define
relationships relationships are going
through a massive transformation a
massive makeover over and um and we
don't necessarily have the skills of how
to deal with all these changes that are
literally happening under our feet so my
mission is to guide people to help
people make sense of what their
relational lives are about friendship at
work romantic relationships Family Ties
and to
develop understandings insights skills
to be able to handle what is probably in
my mind one of of the most important
dimensions of our life without it we
die without it we die M oh we don't die
a natural death necessarily but you it's
a death to the
soul you life without
relationships you mean there are a few
Hermits but the vast majority of us are
socially wired we exist in relationships
we Define ourselves in relationships I
Know Who I Am by being with you I mean
who am I outside of that it's like you
know it's in the presence of the other
that we discover who we are alone
there's no there's nothing to bounce off
of and so I am passionate about the
relational lives of people the
challenges of relationships in the
modern world and as we enter the 21st
century and as machines are entering to
replace people I am interested in how
people heal from broken relationships or
from relationships that broke them
um that's the mission and you've spent a
long time working with people that want
better relationships in a therapeutic
sort of environment as a therapist right
yes I I have been a
psychotherapist for more than 40 years
I'm so compelled I want to start where
we all start which is with our childhood
and the role that plays in the
relationships we then go on to have or
not to have I imagine most of the
couples and people you see you can
understand the way they are today as
adults based on what they experienced
when they were younger or what they
learned a lot a
lot but we are not just what happened to
us we are also who we
become and sometimes we become on the
basis of what happened to us and when
you ask people sometimes what are some
of your most important inner resources
those very resources come from some of
the miseries of their childhood
too so it's not linear it's not bad
leads to bad it's that some absence some
U deprivation can lead to an an acute
awareness of something that makes you
become the exact opposite it's it's a
dynamic dialogue with your childhood
it's not just the
determinism the the determinism that
your childhood will determine what's
going to happen to you later I think
that all of us you know I mean this is
one of there many many Frameworks around
childhood but the one that I wrote about
in mating in captivity was to say that
we all need security and we all also
need Adventure or change or freedom and
that some of us will come out of our
childhood wanting more safety more
protection more connection more
grounding and some of us will come out
of our childhood wanting more space more
freedom more individuality more personal
expression and that doesn't mean it's
static I mean the beauty of us is that
we are forever changing creatures and we
can rewrite the story we can't change
the story as it occurred to us but we
can change its Legacy its meaning its
influence in in the most extraordinary
ways I mean how many people have you how
many have you sat with thousands you
must start to see patterns emerging when
you're when you know your two couple a
couple is sat
there they've got some dysfunction in
their
relationships the guy or the woman
starts
saying describing their childhood and
saying their their parents were never
around you must start to see some
patterns and how that caused dysfunction
and causes dysfunction later in life is
there any patterns that we can use as
stereotypes or hold on to with with
childhood separation AB I wouldn't even
call them a stereotypes I think there
are a lot of patterns but the pattern is
not just what you bring from your
childhood and how it manifests now the
pattern is what two people create that's
the pattern so a pattern could be okay
let's say I grew up and I felt that I
was left to fend for myself that all of
it was on me that I was taking care of
my younger siblings I'm thinking of a
recent episode of the of where should we
begin and you know when he's absent when
he doesn't respond to a request she
doesn't just think oh he doesn't want to
do what I just asked him to do she
instantly goes into the I'm always alone
there's never been anybody there for me
I've always been alone my life is never
going to change why is it always me who
has to do all of this I carry the burden
and the pattern is what she asks that
makes him react that makes her amplify
and it's what I do that makes you be and
do what you do that makes me be what I
do it's a figure eight that's the
pattern and the more he refuses or to
just do it let's say and the more alone
she feels and the more alone she feels
and the more she tests him every time to
see if the next time she asks for
something he's going to actually
respond in kind and since he feels the
pressure and the test and he comes from
a story that says nobody's going to tell
me what to
do that's a dance so couples have dances
and the dance is how you see one person
Trigger or evoke in the other a survival
strategy his survival strategy is nobody
tells me what to do and that survival
strategy is going to then trigger in her
the vulner ability of well if no if you
won't do anything I asked then I'm again
alone and then when that person feels
that alone her survival strategy is to
go and knock at the door and see are you
really not there for
me the dance between the vulnerability
and the survival strategy is one of the
most common patterns in a relationship
and what's really essential to
understand is
that what makes the difference is the
form it is figuring out what is this
figure eight look like in this couple
not the specific detail because once
you've noticed the
loop it doesn't matter what they're
talking about every topic could become a
part of the loop whether it's money kids
sex in-laws
trips it will look alike if I always
think I'm alone and I can't count on you
and I feel abandoned and let down then
that becomes the filter with which I
enter most of these conversations and if
your thing is nobody pushes me and
nobody imposes their will on me because
I you know have been telling my dad for
a long time that he's done being the
boss of me this is the the filter so you
look for those filters and then you
begin to see you know it's like music if
you really listen to a sentence from a
music to a phrase after to the first
four notes you have a good idea of what
are the next four notes MH that's how
you do pattern recognition in couples me
and my partner are going through this I
think at the moment we've figured out
what our figure of eight our pattern is
right tell me it's exactly what you just
said which one I'm the guy she's the
woman in the scenario so you're the
nobody tells me I'm the one to feels
like everything's threatening my
Independence you know and my and I don't
like to be told what to do as
in and so you also so interpret any
request or invitation as a
command as a threat on my Independence
right that's a command which you have to
push back as an intrusion yeah like the
walls are closing in right as a
violation of your and so you do this
yeah and when you do that then she she
goes comes she uh it's almost like I'll
give you an example I'll be sat at home
after work I've come home it's maybe
9:00 p.m. I'm quickly throw up my laptop
and I'm do doing some work um whatever
she says something to me and cuz I'm
kind of busy here I give like a half
acknowledgement and because I've like
not turned away from the laptop or
because I've not given my full attention
she'll then start like asking me
seemingly completely random questions
that she wouldn't ordinar asked me what
do you think of this picking up
something random in the house um what do
you want to drink there's a liter a cup
of water already in front of me and you
know what that does right the more the
more call this the more she starts doing
it to me the more I start giving the
blunt responses but what it means when
you say the more the more is that we
make the
other you are creating a knocker yeah
yeah and she's creating a
withholder the more she knocks the more
you withdraw or withhold the more you
withdraw half attention uhhuh you know
artificial intimacy and the more more
she experiences you as absent and she
comes looking for you in full force and
what that says is that we create the
other person we contribute to making
them the very thing we don't
want if you wanted her to not do this
you could change this in a minute how by
basically stopping for a moment saying
this ritual of acknowledging each other
at the end of a long day means a lot and
actually it doesn't just mean a lot to
her because you don't have to deal with
it because she makes sure that you don't
get
forgotten if she would was not coming
and she didn't and she disappeared for
six days in a row and never came to
check in with you you would begin to
wonder what's going on so she holds the
flame for you yeah if you if you stopped
actually and it's 9:00 you've had your
long Deeds you've been on your own
you've done all your stuff and you
actually said
come here and you took literally 30
seconds for a beautiful kiss a hug a
gaze a moment and then you said I'll be
done in probably 20 minutes I'm excited
to spend some time together you would
relax her nervous system she would not
be you know after you and you would
actually feel like your boundaries have
been
respected but what happens in a couple
is that you want her to change you want
her to stop annoying you and do what you
do doesn't she see that I'm busy I'm
almost done you know why doesn't she
wait and so we always think the other
will change and then my life will
improve but if you actually want your
life to change or your relationship
Dynamic to change you could do it like
this because you're the one who is you
and her right the same I would say the
exact same thing to her by the way this
is so symmetric so I would say to her if
you actually want him to not push you
away here's what you can do if you want
her to not keep knocking then here's
what you can do because when you do what
you do you are increasing her knocking
I've noticed that this is fundamental to
Coupes thinking it says we are not
essential creatures we become someone as
part of the dynamic that we are in with
another
someone this is when people begin to
understand that in couple therapy things
begin to change it's like a light bulb
goes
on I was Al really resonate with the
subo you made that if she stopped
knocking I'd be like what the hell's
going on and i' and I'd eventually end
up lonely and unhappy and you're right
she is carrying the um as you called it
like the flame for the relationship
she's the pursuer yeah you're the
distancer yeah and the distancer doesn't
have to deal with his feelings of
longing or desire for closeness because
the other one is holding up the quot
then why do we go do we go for people
that are are opposites in this regard no
you go for people who Express the part
of you that you don't want to deal
with okay meaning you're telling me I'm
the person who who's from whom being
intruded upon violated my Independence
my Independence but we all have needs
for Independence and we all have needs
for connection and dependence but those
you have outsourced on
her ah so we Outsource the things is
taking care of the feelings that you are
disavowing or the needs that you are
disavowing inside of you why you sh
Versa I mean my thing on top of
it was that no I'm joking I'm joking no
but it's so true do you do you do you
understand 100% we Outsource it's not
that we find someone who's the opposite
is we find it looks like it's the
opposite but what it really is
is we all have needs for that's what I
was saying for for the connection and
for the space or the independence we all
need both we need home and we need
Journey we need predictability and we
need Innovation we need commitment and
we need Freedom we we need both
different degrees but we need both what
happens in a relationship sometimes is
that I assign to you I Outsource to you
the parts of my needs that I am
conflicted about and you are more
conflicted about your dependency needs
with which are actually totally normal
you're much more aware of your
Independence needs that's kind of your
persona and she may be exactly on the
opposite of that it changes when people
begin to actually integrate the part
that the other one is playing and this
realization that if she wasn't coming
after you at some point you would
suddenly
say
wow where is she that is basically the
giveaway and I know I know this in our
relationship I think God is she cuz when
I'm over here I'm over here in New York
at the moment and she's in London doing
her Retreats and stuff she's got like a
breath work bar breathwork do.com a
breathwork retreat she does and when
she's not here not around me I fall into
I can miss her better yeah yeah 100% And
also I fall into really like I'd say
bad balance habits I'm out of balance in
my life I'm I go all in on Independence
and work right but when she I've always
referred to her she's like a
counterbalance in my life because she's
the one that says no we need to go to
the beach for two hours I would never do
that on my own Val and and I appreciate
it so deeply because I go I know what my
life looks like when you're not around
and it is a unsustainable life and they
often say opposites attract I think
she's she's do you tell her so by the
way which part of how much she balances
you how appreciative you are of it how
much you rely on her for that how out of
kilter you would be when if she wasn't
doing so do you actually acknowledge
that and show her the appreciation for
it or is 90% of your speech to her the
the part of the I need my time my
Independence my this my that it's a very
good question
um I would say I don't tell her enough
and at the same time if it's possible
maybe this is a mistake that she knows
and I say she knows for two reasons
reason one is because there are moments
where I express that gratitude to her
and number two is because I'm so open
about it in terms of like publicly which
isn't always the best way to communicate
with someone don't tell me off but I'm
so open about it on this podcast I talk
about and she listens to it she listens
to it and she she's a big fan of yours
as well and
but you're right in the Moment In the
Heat of the Moment I'm all about defense
so I'm like I can descend into blame a
little bit too much you know you know I
once I often like to ask people you know
what's the one thing I said that that
stayed with you that made a difference
and um it was a situation where a person
basically was talking about how
um when they are late when they miss an
appointment when they miss an activity
that a couple had agreed upon or a game
of the children or whatever it was you
know that they make a point of
apologizing and I said to them you
know if you still at a computer at 10:00
and you know and you're apologizing
that's you consider that being
considerate I'm aware and I'm
apologizing but when you apologize about
your absence what you missed what you
didn't do you basically still say I'm
super important I'm that important but I
couldn't be there but if you actually
said I'm so
thankful that you're here because I
could not have stayed at the office late
I could not have gone to that last
minute dinner I could not have gone and
so seen so and so if you were not here
and instead of apologizing you thank
then you are actually saying I couldn't
do this without you which means I am an
independent person who is completely
interdependent with
you and that
interdependence is the part that the
independent person is struggling
with it's whatever you are doing and
this is when you said she balances me
she tells me let's go to the be whatever
you are doing is bolstered by someone
who is making this possible for you and
that acknowledgement it's not just to be
nice and to say thank you it humbles you
it says I could not do this without
you that gives the other person not a
sense that they are Superfluous or
intrusive or annoying or choosing the
wrong moment but that they
matter that they have a presence and a
meaning in your life and that is a
secret to a
connection making the other person
person know that they matter and have
meaning in my life yeah I couldn't do it
without
you I'm having a huge day at business or
a huge day at work and I can do this and
I can stay late and I because whatever
you've taken care of 10 different things
that would make it possible for me to
have my mind completely focused I'm here
I'm with a St pel you know I'm talking
orever all the other guests are and I
can do that because there's someone
there that has taken care of all of the
stuff I don't have to worry about and
when you acknowledge that and you thank
a person for that you're basically
saying I couldn't do this if you didn't
do that that's the
interdependence our relationships you
know I think we all certainly I think I
have for much in my life and I say that
because I look at my actions so what I
might say is different to how I think
I've behaved over the last I don't know
10 10 15 years we see them as kind of an
afterthought to everything else and many
regards so the amount of effort I put
into my businesses and to the podcast
and to every little detail the
creativity the thought the brainstorming
all of that relationships we kind of all
just think they're just they just happen
and if it doesn't happen perfectly then
it's broken and I need to find a new
one yeah that's a terrible way to think
I mean and everybody knows it if you
give the best of yourself at work if you
bring the leftovers home if when you
come home you say I've given everything
I had now I'm just putting my feet on
the table I just need to chill I don't
want to make any effort you know slowly
your relationship degrades period and
then there's all kinds of ways it ends
none of them are particularly joyful and
um basically if people were able to put
a little bit of creativity attention
attention into their relationships as
they do with their customers or their
guests relationships would be doing a
lot better and my profession would be
seeing a lot less people I mean there's
no
doubt and why are people so lazy so
complacent so
unimaginative with their relationships
at home I mean I see so many people when
you like here you know you're not taking
out your phone you're not you're looking
at me you're paying attention on
occasion you look for your questions and
where we go but basically you're you're
with me but at home you're if you do
this or this looking at my phone you
know um and and then when the person
tells you something really important you
go
uhhuh uh-huh you know and you're kind of
there but not present and that's the
beginning of a kind of modern loneliness
actually is that this idea that you can
share something really important to
someone who is half there half there and
I think that that's what's happening
with a lot of younger people these days
is that they experience a lot of half
darness and that begins to cultivate a
real sense of loneliness that has to do
not with I'm physically alone that has
to do with do I matter who hears me who
cares who pays attention who
notices you know so I
I sometimes the advice is very banal you
know it's to tell people put your
freaking phone down take an hour and put
your phone down and but I'm busy huh but
I'm busy
well that you will be busy and there
won't be a relationship sooner or later
there won't be a relationship it's not
difficult you can wait you can wait for
the kids to grow up if there are kids
involved things but in the end it it
there wasn't just because someone was on
their phone well it's not just the on
the phone it's on the phone mean means I
am continuously saying something is more
important than you we come last we're a
cactus we don't need to be watered we
can survive in a
desert it's called there's a term I've
been using for this that is I borrow
from something else it's called
ambiguous loss have you ever heard of
this term ambiguous loss yeah no
ambigious loss is a term that was
developed by a colleague Pauline boss
wonderful psychologist she talked about
what happens when you have some parent
for example that has
Alzheimer they are physically present
but they are psychologically gone
they're emotionally absent and you can't
really mourn them because they're still
physically there but you caught in this
in between in this ambiguous loss on the
other side you can have somebody who is
deployed
hostage miscarriage they are emotionally
very present but they are physically
absent in both cases it's an ambiguous
loss you can't are they still there or
are they gone who knows when we live
with this phone thing when we are
because you've been at work you've been
at the computer you come home you think
ah I'm so happy to finally let go of the
computer you turn on the TV you turn on
the TV and then you turn on the phone at
the same time you're watching here
you're watching there and there's a
person next to you
and most likely they often do the same
thing in the end
too and gradually you know there is less
and less of a thread of conversation of
connection of Joy of Sex of intimacy all
of what you know that becomes ambiguous
loss somebody is there but they're not
really present I'm I'm I'm you know do
is there a difference between me and the
sofa it's comfy it's routine you sit on
me but comfy and routine does do not
give us joy or
meaning or
relevance or connection and that's what
we still seem to want so it means saying
to people you know it's actually not
very very
complicated what did people do for so
centuries they took
walks that's one of the few times you
can't
click so take a walk don't sit don't try
to do you know take a walk around the
block and just be in motion then you're
parallel you know it's not face to face
it's side by side and you and you can
talk about the day if you instead of
just saying stop stop stop you just said
you know let's go for a walk it's London
but still you can you can you know and
that you do half an hour walk it
will you'll come back to me and you tell
me what it will do but it it's amazing
how these small interventions that are
playful creative not
digging change the dynamic of the
relationship because she is only
pursuing
you in part because of how much you are
withdrawing you change she change if you
want to change the other change
yourself once you understood the figure
eight and how we create the other you
understand that if you do something else
sooner or later they do something else
too so if you want to change the other
change
you this is part of the question you
asked me right what are some of the
essential understandings of working with
relational systems this is true at work
in companies this is true in Intimate
relationship this is not just for
romantic love this is foundations of
relational
systems feedback loop it's called in
cybernetics
so many busy couples can feel the spark
in their relationship waning away slowly
but work isn't necessarily the first
place you look like pulling out the
phone at dinner isn't necessarily the
place people look because that seems so
small so they aim at bigger things
they'll say I don't know something
bigger but do you believe are you saying
that you believe a lot of it much of it
often starts with those small moments of
disconnection where the person basically
ends up becoming the sofa the gments
call them bids for connection bids for
connection bids you know it's the little
things it's the the difference between
turning towards someone or turning away
you know when you read something this is
a classic example they give you read
something do you actually say hey did
you read this let me send you this
article that's a bid for connection it's
not a big declaration but it says we're
in this together when I see something
that's interesting that I think you
would like to read as well I share it
I'm thinking of you I know you exist
even if I'm not with you do you know
what my partner said to me something
about a year ago and I and it we stayed
with me because I thought that's such a
strange thing to say she said to me when
we were in conflict resolution so we
were talking about things um she said
you know why I send you things on
Instagram in Instagram DMs like I'll be
out here now in New York so she'll
she'll if she sees something interesting
on Instagram she sends it to me she goes
you've stopped acknowledging it I used
to just like double tap on it or make a
comment back she go you stopped you
stopped acknowledging it and I thought
why does that matter why does it like
you send me something I watch the funny
video I crack on with my day because
it's like when you receive a birthday
gift do you think yeah when you buy a
birthday gift is it important to give it
yeah okay that's
reason I
mean how would she know that you watched
it
if there is no acknowledgement and the
acknowledgement is not about the video
or the DM the acknowledgement is we
share something well it's even worse
because it says seen on Instagram so it
says that I've seen it yes but I but but
the seen that means that I have seen the
video the acknowledgement is we are in
we are part of a thread we're connected
she's absolutely right so in that sense
when you people lose the spark it is a
lot of these small details that people
say so much in the beginning you know
all the positive stuff that people use
and it it's it's actually only more
important with time rather than less
important with time the the death of a
relationship is when people take each
other for granted and when you stop
acknowledging those things it is part of
the mechanisms of taking for granted I
had a really good friend of mine um sit
with me a couple of weeks ago and she
has been married to a CEO she's also a
CEO herself and she's just going through
a divorce now and I sat with her in
America and she said to me you know he
was very busy I was very busy we had
this kid and I just think I don't I
don't really know what happened along
the way it just seems like we fell out
of love and ever since she said that to
me it made me think that it is often
quite a gradual process this in apart
and this kid coming into the picture as
well complicates that what she said to
me was you know we we we're both had our
businesses to take care of and then we
had the kid as well so the relationship
was I guess the residual beneficiary it
got whatever was left and that's caused
this divorce now and the child is I
guess going to have to live in two
different homes so I have two two
thoughts about this you know the first
thing is um this is the first time in
history that the survival of the family
depends on the happiness of the
couple if the couple doesn't nurture
itself there is no family you don't stay
married because you have to women have
an economic independence in her case at
least to be able to leave you have
divorce laws you can go so the only
thing that holds the couple together you
don't get excommunicated none of it it's
the relationship quality if you don't
have that there is no family here's your
child and the second thing is when she
says we just fell out of love that's not
the way it goes love is a verb and you
conjugate it actively in many tenses
it's a practice if you stop doing all
those things that you're telling me the
acknowledgments the the the hells the
thank yous the um the sharing of the of
the of the the videos Etc all of that
cushioning when that thins out it means
that you have not been conjugating the
verb love is not a permanent state of
enthusiasm that just exists do you know
a single person who would treat their
business the way that some people treat
their
relationships the business would be
dead this is the and every and and you
know I say it with kind of emphatically
but I'm thinking I'm not saying anything
somebody doesn't know you have you take
that kind of lazy attitude towards your
shop end of
story and therefore end of relationship
but it's not that it just happened it's
that they stopped doing saying
expressing showing feeling giving
receiving sharing those are the verbs
wanting imagining playing experiencing
exploring those are verbs that have to
do with relationship ship and
love on that first point about this is
being the first time in history where
the health and happiness of the
relationship determined whether the
family stayed together not the church or
some some other external pressure could
this go to explain why people are having
less and less kids as well because they
don't feel as secure as they once did I
think this a little bit about my by
because with my partner I feel like
she's said or indirectly said that she
will be she'll feel happy and safe to
have a child when she feels like more
secure in the
relationship and you know imagine Once
Upon a Time the SEC you just knew that
you were going to stay with them
regardless and you also knew that if you
had sex you had a good chance of being
pregnant true yeah that's the first and
foremost big change that took place so
and sex was mostly a woman's marital
Duty not that long ago so you know
um I think
that many people the Lesser they have
the more children they have because
children becomes an expression of
abundance of care of more hands to help
of the riches of a family um people who
have less food have more
children it's not people who are more
insecure or live in more precarious
situations I don't think that that is
the reason I think that there is a
certain kind of
um attitude towards not wanting to give
up the Comforts of one's
life the freedom the comings and goings
that make some people not want to have
children and then there's also the fact
that for a long time you didn't have a
choice and some people today want to
exercise that choice you know but you're
talking
about the love that goes and
you asked me before you know one of the
subjects that I'm very interested in in
light of that is conflict and I called
the course that I just created turning
conflict into
connection because it's
easy to look at your situation and then
begin to see the strife and the
arguments and the bickering and the
conflict and to focus on the conflict
but this conflict is occurring because
there is a fraud connection there's a
tear in the fabric of
connection and that too if you say to
people would you run a business that
allowed for that kind of conflict and
bickering to take place
nobody and and yet you normalize it in
your relationship you think that that's
that's an okay thing it's like I mean if
I give you an assignment that you know
say I would say of all the things we
talked about I I I would love for you to
choose three things that you're going to
do differently change and that you know
would improve the relationship you don't
have to go look very far you've already
listed the half a dozen and and then you
stay with it you you you commit yourself
to it you don't do it contingent on what
she does you don't say oh I didn't and
she still did the same give it a time
and hold yourself to it you will see
relationship is not something that
happens out there it's actually
something that we are very much in
charge of creatively like a business and
by the way a business is made up of
relationships as well products but
relationships leadership is
relationships it's Vision its
efficiencies Etc it's operations but it
is also relationships if those don't
work you can have the best product if I
want to be a master in conflict
resolution in my romantic relationships
man and woman let's just use that two
men to women
is there any differences between between
the way that genders typically approach
conflict
resolution because there's stereotypes
right that men don't want to talk and
that women want to
talk yes but when you have two women
there's often one that doesn't want to
talk as well okay I think there is
gender there is culture there is
linguistics there's a lot of different
things that play themselves out but it's
not in great couples you will attribute
certain things to
gender that in other couples you will
attribute to
roles okay because the behaviors are not
that different so we there's a whole um
I think one of the most important thing
is
that instead of asking what are we
fighting
about ask yourself what are we fighting
for like when you go into the Beering
around you know you see I'm busy why are
you bringing up all these stupid
questions now that you what are you
fighting for what she's fighting for is
to connect to have some time with you to
have attention to to not just kind of go
through the day do everything and let
this thing kind of die on the
vine you know there are relationships
that are not dead and there are
relationships that are
alive tell me the same as business well
you can be you can survive or you can
Thrive you can survive and go through
the motions or you can be alive erotic
radiant vibrant vital creative
curious it's those experiences you know
now we use eroticism in as a life force
not just in the sexual sense of the word
that aliveness
gives you energy for a lot of things
that you do
elsewhere you would not be here the same
way if she wasn't
there
and how do you cultivate aliveness how
do you cultivate the erotic is essential
so when I say to people what are you
fighting for usually people fight for
about three things they fight for
trust they fight to feel like the the
other person has their back they fight
for recognition to be valued and they
fight for control they want to feel that
their needs their beliefs their
expectations have priority too control
trust recognition those are probably
three of the main things people fight
for but it doesn't look like that it
looks like they're fighting over you
know money or time together or how often
they have sex or you know that kind of
stuff so that's a big one about how you
deal with conflict what is productive
conflict and what is destructive
conflict because conflict in itself is
intrinsic to all relationships people
fight people want to have Equity they
want to have Justice they want to be
heard they want to you know so it's a
useful
thing but we all know what fighting
looks like that is not
useful and that is destructive and that
harms arms you and that you've seen when
you are a kid and that travels with you
for the rest of your life so we we know
all of those versions
too um and I think that these days we
live in a society that is also more and
more conflict avoidant we really don't
know how to go we have so less much less
face Toof face with other
people there's a question that I have
loved asking recently that has to do
with conflict when you grew up
did you play freely on the street yeah
okay do you know do you don't have kids
right no but you have friends with
little ones yeah my my brother has three
kids he's under the he's only one year
older than me as well all right how much
do his kids play play freely on the
street um they don't play fre on the
street so to me this little piece of
information
is so important because what happens
when you played freely on the street you
had unchoreographed
unmonitored unscripted free play with
other kids with whom you learned
friction rubbing fighting making up
competing collaborating being jealous
making alliances breaking alliances
recreating you learned a ton of social
skills and dealing with conflict and dis
agreement and reuniting and all of that
this entire universe of experimentation
that children had
gone and you really don't learn it by
playing games on the
screen so we find ourselves a little bit
socially atrophied then comes the
pandemic and comes the virtualization of
Our Lives there's a lot of things come
come come coming together here and we
are more and more unable to deal with
conflict and we polarize people keep
telling you how do you stay connected
with people who disagree with you who
have different points of view different
politics different belief systems
Etc so we are conflict avoidant we lack
the social skills we are socially
atrophied and we polarize and what's the
cure I mean I think that a major piece
of it is um and I hope Alpha generation
is actually showing us a little more of
that is you know close the screen and go
outside and play and meet people in
real in whatever version two or groups
Sports no sports but it's about it's not
about structure activities it's about
happen stance Serendipity chance chance
is an essential piece of our life why is
this so important because if everything
is controlled everything is predictable
every Tech techology is trying to give
you a polished friction free answer to
every problem that you have you learn to
not tolerate
uncertainty and if you can't tolerate
uncertainty you become increasingly more
anxious and if you become increasingly
more anxious we're going to talk about
the Mental Health crisis and this Mental
Health crisis doesn't come from
nowhere it's connected to a whole bunch
of things that are happening in the
world around us let your kids go and
have
sleepovers connect with other people
don't just stay in your little nuclear
system are younger Generations less
resilient in your view because they
didn't get to play on the street they
are definitely less able to deal with
um with disagreement divergences of
opinions conflict they polarize but so
do other people older people too there
is definitely more polarization because
they but what they do show is
a lot increased levels of
anxiety um increased levels of all kinds
of other symptomatologies of around
mental health from eating disorders you
know you name it that start earlier and
earlier difficulty experimenting making
mistakes not being so perfectionistic
not attributing everything to themselves
as I'm not enough I'm not enough like
there the whole manufactured insecurity
going on so those things yes I think
that you notice it we notice it parents
notice it teachers notice it you know do
I I think we could say that there is
less resilience but I I think that
that's a dangerous statement because
there are plenty of kids who are
extraordin resilient in very very
challenging
circumstances I would not want to say
younger kids these days you know but I
do think that they struggle with certain
things uncertainty is essential
you can't innovate without
uncertainty without an appetite for it
yes yeah you need to be able to take
risks you need to be able to take
chances you need to be able to try out
certain things if it instantly becomes
you know I'm afraid to fail I cannot I
have to know before I even try I have to
know in advance etc etc we it it doesn't
just affect one
individual why did you write this book
mating and captiv you could have written
about anything but for some reason you
felt compelled enough to take on this
subject of unlocking erotic intelligence
why why did you write about
this at a time this book is 17 years ago
it's still it lives as if it was
yesterday um I guess that that means it
touched something that had a
timelessness to it which was really how
do we reconcile
the two sets of fundamental human needs
that we have never wanted to reconcile
in one relationship our need for
security safety
predictability dependability and our
need for Freedom exploration change risk
they have traditionally they come from
different sources they pull us in
different directions and we've rarely
really wanted them to be in one
relationship today we want a passionate
marriage or a passionate you know
relationship and those two things have
never had to do because they they demand
different
ingredients so I was very interested in
that what does it mean that romantic
love has promised us that there is one
relationship in which we can have all of
that there was one Rel reason I was
interested in writing this book because
I thought this is you know we used to
have religion to experience belonging
and continuity and identity and then we
had family for security and economic
support and children and social status
but now we want the partner to be a best
friend and a trusted Confidant and a
passionate lover and on top of it I want
you to help me become the best version
of myself and I'm going to start calling
you a soulmate soulmate used to be the
realm of the Divine not a
person so it is an incredible thing if
we've never expected more from one
relationship and asked one person to
give us what usually an entire Village
used to provide that interested me so
something must be broken there I mean
it's just an incredible shift it's a
unique thing it's an It's a grand
experiment in our in our life and then
the third part was sexual you know
sexuality went through major
Transformations it went from duty to
desire it went from you know being
inexcusably linked to children to being
now I mean if you only have two kids you
have sex for the Long Haul for pleasure
and connection there's no other reason
so what does that look like and why do
people always say that sexual problems
are the consequence of relationship
problems which is sometimes true but in
many
instances sex and intimacy they are they
are a parallel process they're not just
a metaphor of each other and so I
thought I've seen many couples improved
their relationship and it did nothing
for the sex but I've seen couples who
when the sexuality changes between them
it transforms the relationship and so
that demands a deeper understanding of
what is sexuality not what do you do you
know and how often do you do it and how
hard and how often and how how many I
mean the measurable stuff that is you
know sex had become this thing that you
measure rather than you know where do
you
go inside of you with another what is
the experience like you know what is the
meaning of sex not what is the frequency
of sex and all these questions had not
been discussed much certainly not in the
field of couples therapy and not in in
the general culture at large and to
explain that dilemma seemed to have been
something that till today people found
really there's not an answer by the way
there there's not an answer no the book
tells you that because relationship
issues are not binaries they're not
black and white they're not problems
that you solve they're paradoxes that
you
manage the strength of the book is that
it didn't have enough answer the
strength of the book is that it told you
you have to learn to live with some of
these
contradictions people don't want to hear
that people want people want to know the
two steps to fix their sexless
relationship in 60 seconds yeah well
they can they won't find that with me
but they keep finding something else
with me see you want your freedom you
want your travel you want to be here you
want to do your podcast you want to do
the stuff that is interesting to you but
you also want your girlfriend you do
want both and you're looking for how how
do I not bring all my passion all my
energy my creativity my erotic charge my
imagination my curiosity everything to
this part of my life and I let that
other thing dry up and once you will
find that not it's not so much a balance
it's really you know um a distribution
of your resources you will experience a
very different level of satisfaction in
your life because you won't half the
time be guilty when you look back
through different cultures they that
true yeah of course it's true because
you said it so of course it's true not
because I said it no it's true because
everything you say is true oh come on no
absolutely not I'm sound very confident
but I actually never think I'm right no
but I think you're right that's what I'm
saying um on this contradiction point
about us expecting everything from one
person are you telling me that we just
kind of have to live with the
contradiction that that creates because
you're right we want spontaneity and
excitement and you know all of these
kind of erotic fantasies but at the same
time we want safety and belonging and
familiarity which seem like a
contradiction is it is is it that we
just have to live with the contradiction
or are we meant to be
polygamous
and a bit more I don't know Reckless and
have lots of different partners and you
know you know like some of the people
used to have throughout history and some
people have in different
religions I think it's too separate
questions why ask one of them is about
monogamy and the other one's
about yeah well the other one is about
how you keep a relationship
alive and um that's that I think we have
somewhat addressed right um it involves
doing more things you the contradiction
is when you stand you know if you really
want to stand it's actually about
constantly moving the weight from one
side to another it's not about
neutralizing the two polarities it's
about playing with these polarities so
there are times of the day or times of
the year or times in your life when you
know you want a bundle and then there
are times when you want to explore and
play and be be creative and curious and
do unusual thing so I don't think that
it is inherently impossible to do it in
relationship but it demands activity
look every system every relational
system every company straddles stability
and change continuity and Innovation if
you don't change you filiz and you die
so will your relationship so will your
company if you change all the time and
you're running spinning spinning
spinning spinning you will deregulate
and you will be chaotic and you will be
exhausted and you will forget get what
you're even running towards so nature
knows that we continuously straddle
these two polarities that's what I call
the contradiction you know
but monogamy is a different question
about that it's it has to do with what
do we think are the viable relational
Arrangements at this
moment for whom is this a model that
appeals and um and it has opened up a
whole Vista about what does consensual
non- monogamy look like or what does
polyamory look like for whom is this you
know an expression of Liberation and and
for whom is this actually rather
torturous and it's and I think the what
it says to us is that you can't have a
one- siiz fits all and when it comes to
love relationships we have usually not
been the most Innovative you know family
models have changed but couple models
haven't changed that
much romantic Romantics and
realists yes you discussed this in
chapter one of your book how do you
define a
romantic Romantics are
aspirational Romantics are live in the
realm of the imagination they live in
the realm of how do you transcend the
limits how do you project yourself
outside side of the narrowness of your
own reality boundaries Consciousness
body Etc when I say aspirational
idealistic um longing
yearning Discovery exploration unknown a
kind of an active engagement with the
unknown and and a and a reverence for
the connection
realists are more pragmatic realists you
know are basically you know instead of
this is not
possible there must be more they say
this is fine as is why should there be
more and um this is a conversation I
just use these two terms because they
were handy it's not because I had entire
definitions of them but I understood
that in relationship you often have one
person who says why you always want
more and then one person who says but
there is
so many possibilities and then the other
person says yes but so many mindfields
or landmines do you see a gender
difference between those two typically
ever
no I think that what makes the gender
difference is the
dynamic as well I mean um no I I I I
refuse to
just make it a a man women because I see
the dynamic in all couples and there
it's less defined around gender and more
defined around childhood story or or or
gender identification in the broad sense
of the I
no I I mean yes in the you know the
classic old line that you could see in
the hetero couple is when Mr says but
it's like so that is cliche you know
everything's fine and if she was fine
everything would be fine is speaking a
man's strength though is what speaking
Yeah communicating about how they feel
is that a strength that it depends how
it's said you know because people think
of um intimacy as verbal communication
often it's one of the things I saw in
chapter three of your book that we so
here's the thing I don't buy the thing
that men talk
less I do think that yes men are
often uh emptied out from the vocabulary
of emotions by a seven it's like
siphoned out of them the socialization
of boys does not really
prioritize an an active engagement with
one's emotional life and one's
interiority okay it's much better to be
stoic to be Fearless to be competitive
to be you know those kind of values are
more but when I sit alone with men it's
not because they don't have a vocabulary
that they don't have the
feelings and I've been a therapist of
many men for for decades for it was
actually something I actively sought and
when you take your time and you listen
and you support the the
expression things will come out and they
when they come out here's the thing when
a woman talks to
you many times you know that she's
already said that to somebody
else that which doesn't diminish it but
when a man talks to you you know that
he's hearing himself for the first
time himself
but that's not because that's what men
are that's because that's what we make
men to be that's how we socialize
men um I think that this notion that
women want more connection look you were
asking me about sex before I think every
gender has been given license to what
needs they're allowed to have publicly
and officially and in what language
they're entitled to talk about them so
men will not necessarily talk about the
need for tenderness connection care uh
intimacy um
holding um be because that is not the
vocabulary that has been assigned to
them so they will talk about it in the
language of
sex women have basically not been given
the license to say what they want
sexually that is really not what they
have been educated to develop so they
have learned that they are allowed to
speak about relational needs and wrapped
in their relational needs are all kinds
of other longings for sexual intimacy
for seduction for pleasure for
connection every gender is allowed to
ask for the same things but in a
different vocabulary men are allowed to
talk about sex women are allowed to talk
about intimacy
but that's not the fact that is not the
same as saying men and women want other
things actually they are more similar
than we think they are and all research
supports that but it's just the
socialization is
causing a different a different uh
effect like we like to think that you
know men's sexuality it's autonomous
it's unprompted it's spontaneous they
don't need anything they're always ready
they're always looking for an outlet you
know as and that you know men are
creatures of Nature and women are
creatures of meaning whereas for her
it's the context it's the quality of the
relationship it's the that elicits the
desire Etc ET I mean
seriously on what basis are we saying
things like this I mean you want to know
men have an a range of very Deep
Emotions that completely affect how they
experience sex you know the rise in um
feminism
and equality of the genders in every
regard do do you think that has had
implications
for relationships and specifically
sex in a way that you've seen over the
last
decade because you've been working with
thousands of couples over the last
couple of decades so is there any way
that feminism or gender equality has
influenced sexual
Dynamics I tell I asked it because it's
one of the chapters in your book from
you know was it 17 years ago or
something talks about how some of
America's best features the belief of
democracy equality consensus building um
compromise fairness and mutual tolerance
can when carried to
punctiliously I'm so glad you knew what
word you'd written because I had no idea
how to say that word into the bedroom
result in very boring sex
yes sex is not always politically
correct sometimes we demonstrate during
the
day against the very same things that we
delight at night if it's playful if it's
consensual if it's
voluntary that feels like a
contradiction you understand it's but so
do children children play prisoners and
children play enironment and victims and
doctors and patients would they
understand that when they play they
enter a universe of as
if nobody wants to be pinned down and
tied up you know for
real against their will as in a situ you
know non consensually a nonc
consensually and with the mean and
without the meaning that says this is
for pleasure this is for connection this
is for surrender this is for this very
powerful
ritual you know when kids are tying each
other up because they are the prisoners
they are not tolerating it because they
know that they are in the realm of play
as if make belief and it gives it the
fun and different meaning nobody wants
to
be
trapped who when it becomes real you
know if you play hide and seek the most
amazing thing is when you're hiding is
to know that somebody's looking for you
but the minute you begin to wonder are
they still looking for you the thrill
turns into Terror this is what happens
in sex
too you know you have to it's extremely
important to differentiate when it is
sexual when it's a form of play when
it's a particular practice you
enjoy and everything around it is Con is
coming together to clarify
that are you seeing couples struggling
though with these sort of newly defined
gender roles as it relates to their sex
lives and as we said like feminism and
the equality of the Sexes and all is it
has it changed anything I mean I think
that one thing is to talk about sexual
rights and one thing is to talk about
sexual pleasure and experience I think
you know I was I was teaching this
course yesterday I think it's about 97%
of research on desire is about women
what does that say to you that says that
we think women have challenges around
desire men don't have to be researched
because the assumption is they're always
interested just to G them an opportunity
which is so not true yeah but the
science is completely bought into the
bias what's the the difference though
why does it matter whe if if all the
research is are you getting different
results from men and women no because
because yes the the the the experiences
are different but what it says is that
the science has decided that women need
to be helped around desire yeah yeah
that that they have hyposexual desire
disorder you know today it's that in the
past it was the opposite that we were
researching and that men don't need to
be researched because because men don't
have challenges around desire
and be that is that first of all it
leaves many men unattended to it puts an
unfair burden onto the women that is not
about feminism that is about but science
and political changes and social changes
they are in they intersect with each
other have women you know changed
fundamentally around the fact that at
least in the West in most situations
hopefully sex is no longer just a woman
woman's marital duty but that it is also
about her desire her pleasure their
connection together that is huge yeah I
mean we first separated sex from
reproduction when we got contraception
then we separated reproduction from sex
when we got artificial ways to conceive
and now we are separated Anatomy from
gender and those are huge revolutions
that change the way we conceive of the
relationship you know we used to think
sex elderly people that is the weirdest
thing possible but when is elderly
people start these days I mean we
understand that there is a way to stay
intimately physically sensually
connected till till the end of your life
are you having more and more couples
come to you and this is difficult I
guess because maybe it's just more
people talking about it now but are you
having more couples come to you that are
experiencing problems in the bedroom
sexlessness in their relationships of
course but what does that mean
sexlessness because you know in a in in
a in a relationship or in a culture
where the woman's experience doesn't
really
matter there may be sex but that may be
miserable sex do you think there's a lot
of miserable sex of course you know and
when women don't have desire is it
really that they have less desire or is
it that they don't have desire for the
sex they can have
in order to want sex it needs to be sex
that is worth
wanting well my I've said this before
but it's worth saying now again my
partner turned around to me one day and
said I don't like having sex with you
and I was shocked I was like this was
super early into our relationship and as
a very young man I didn't understand
what that meant very emasculated by it I
thought there some must she must be
broken in some way there must be some
kind of medical defect maybe she needs
some pills or a doctor or something we
ended up breaking up we spent a year
apart she ended up doing some work on
herself I did a little bit of work on
myself we got back
together uh and went on a bit of a
journey together to find out what the
actual answer was and it turns out it
wasn't that she didn't like having sex
or having sex with me she very much
enjoys sex but there was a series of
blockages and I almost describe it like
I thought sex was one language
Spanish and it turns out she thought she
was speaking French and I just assume
because she wasn't speaking Spanish that
we couldn't have sex basically mhm and
at some point I started to view it as
maybe there's 10 different languages or
five different languages of sex and
maybe my job is to learn the language
that she is speaking and I have to say
and I say this I give this conclusion
because there's a lot of people that are
in that situation right now I know that
because I'd say at one point about 20%
20 to 40% of my friendship group
were we have a great sex life now
um and I say that because I think
couples often think they just can't turn
it around they think that when one
partner turns and says I'm not enjoying
this they think it's the other person's
broken we managed to turn it around um
it's
wonderful it's a it's a it it's
wonderful and what is not said often
enough is that when people are able to
change this it changes the whole
relationship mhm that's what I said
before and I said you can change the
kitchen but it won't change the bedroom
but when you change the bedroom it
changes the people who walk into the
kitchen and it's very very important and
and but it's you need to do things you
can't talk about not having sex put it
differently you you it's difficult to
want to have more sex by talking about
not wanting to have sex yeah you have to
try new things yeah and that means you
take chances you risk you explore
together and when it doesn't work you
try something else and that is what
people often find really challenging
they'd rather take it as a criticism and
then they defensive and then they
Counterattack and then you say to her
there's something wrong with you etc etc
you know what really strugg I struggled
with was that first day when I tried to
initiate sex and then I basically got
rejected
that created this almost anxiety every
going forward and then there was maybe
about a year not even a year maybe less
than that I know six months where if I
if ID like tried to initiate sex I'd be
like rejected and that kind of just
totally turned me off and it it was even
when we fixed a situation I almost had
to do a lot of work on myself just to
because then she starts initiating all
the time when we when we get out of the
other end of the situation when we
resolve it and then that's basically a
problem because I've learned this habit
that she has to initiate sex now because
there was periods for six months where I
was just rejected all the time and uh
yeah that was difficult because I tell
you I tell you what when you've got to
get an erection the last thing you want
to be doing is thinking and thinking and
thinking am I going to be rejected is
does she want to have it to you know
it's the last thing you want to be
thinking so this fear of rejection is
probably one of the most important
emotional or sexual vulnerab abilities
for many
men um it's part of what is so alluring
in porn by the way you never reject it
in point she never says not now she
always says me too more more
more and that takes care of one of the
very important sexual vulnerabilities
that many men grapple with by the way
the next one would be um you're also
never
incompetent you never have performance
anxiety it doesn't matter whatever you
do you do it's for you so that takes
care of the second vulnerability and the
third one is that you never have to
wonder is she enjoying it because she
only screams and makes sure that she she
lets whoever the actor is know how
phenomenal he is so and also you've
searched out the fantasy that you want
so you're getting absolutely there's no
rejection in the fantasy so it's very
interesting thing when you look at what
does porn do for many men is it takes
care of three major emotional dilemmas
around sex it's it's not that it just
takes care of the sex it takes care of
the vulnerabilities the emotional
vulnerabilities around sex that's a real
different way of understanding when you
say to people what are you looking
at are you not concerned that with
artificial artificial intelligence on
the way in virtual reality that we
literally if if porn is taking care of
those vulnerabilities that are standing
in the way of Many Men so will
Bots yeah exactly so will machines ever
more so a machine I put a headset on I
buy the machine on the internet you know
and then I can talk to me and I have an
augmented reality and they never say no
and they know exactly what I like and
they accompany me everywhere and I don't
have to feel like I want too much or too
little or I'm doing it wrong or anything
yeah absolutely it's a fantastic
idealistic World in which one can enter
scary and
understandable especially as people are
getting
lonelier they they'll P they'll see that
as a substitute
for the real thing maybe a better
substitute for the real thing in some
people's minds yes those who will seek
it out will want you to will want to
believe that it is um a good substitute
you look concerned I
I it's a world that I don't know yet
that I'm watching
when I say I don't know yet I know I
know plenty but I I
I there are things that are changing
where I say I'm excited this is
phenomenal and then there are things
that are changing that I'm saying where
is this taking
us and I'm a lot more
cautious and this is one of them when
couples do come to you with sexlessness
in their relationship again we have to
Define what sexlessness is but that they
stopped having sex it's been six months
since they've had sex oh six months why
not 16 years you've had
that six months it don't yes I mean when
we talk about a block some you know a a
a breach an
impass a shutdown we're not talking
months and by the way this is not people
this is you your best friends and you
don't know I asked them and I was
shocked you know that's why where should
we begin became so people began to see
that this is not just some others or
just them that it actually is very
common um and so sexlessness is not
about frequency though at some point for
some people it means nothing nothing for
years and then you ask do you still kiss
do you hold do you touch do you rub skin
do you is there any physicality still is
there affection that may not be sexual
touch but that is affectionate touch so
you you you you really look at a broad
you know definition and then you ask
what what you know what is it that you
would want do you do you are you
prepared to take the chance I don't want
that I don't I want to know how how I
get back from that place but also I want
to know how I avoid getting to that
place it's two separate answers I guess
there's 16 years in no sex how do we get
back so first and foremost maybe this is
a place to start when I think about the
conversations I have about sex with the
people I work with individuals or
couples and and I think probably the
best way for you is is to to listen to
it in in the podcast episodes because
you you you you can hear how how one
begins to have this conversation it's
that sex is not about a five minute
foreplay that is just in preparation for
the real thing and the real thing in a
straight couple is penetration and
orgasm and then you know it
worked that model that in performance
model of you know with an outcome is so
not what I'm talking about this is what
couples have had for centuries people
have had sex I mean you can do it and
feel nothing that's not the goal so I
don't care how often I'm care about the
quality of the experience that the
connection you have with yourself and
with another and so it has we talk about
touch we talk about giving touch and
taking touch we talk about fantasy
imagination we talk about how do you ask
for the things that you like but that
doesn't mean just touch me here touch me
there is how do you communicate sexually
what is that transl translation from
Spanish to French you know how do you
say to somebody I enjoy this I would
enjoy that more how do you create a
ulary that isn't negative and critical
and castrating how do you pay attention
to how the other person is responding
and not just say why don't you like this
everybody else likes this that kind of
stuff so it's it's very very rich you
know and the definition of sex is really
Way Beyond this and so you start to ask
people about their their imaginative
life around what excites them around
Peak experiences that they have had
around the kind of touch that they enjoy
around what what do you look for in sex
is it a communion is it a spiritual
union is it an a free experience of
being dominated of being of giving
yourself over to someone of being
naughty of not having to be responsible
and take care of other people which you
do the whole day what do you look for
insect where do you go what do you seek
to express there these are conversations
a lot of people most people have never
had sometimes one person in the
relationship doesn't want to have that
conversation right and the other person
does then I meet with them alone okay
and and because some things need to be
sometimes articulated separately first
you know what is it sometimes it has to
do with smell and Buddy and and
sometimes it has to do with trauma
sometimes it has to do with lingering
resentments sometimes it has to do with
a fundamental inequality in the
relationship in which one person
expects and assumes and it it what
blocks the sex can it's a sleuth work
it's you know it's it's not just it's
stopped does sometimes couple say to you
in private that I'm just not attracted
to them anymore of course sometimes they
say it flat out to each other too people
say hurtful things yes and sometimes
it's I I can't believe somebody would be
attracted to me I don't find myself
attractive I have been ill or I have
struggled with weight or I have had
addiction issues or I Lots the sex
intersects with a lot of things it
intersects with your health the vast
majority of couples 55
up that stop being sexual is actually
because of the men in hetero couples
because the men are often on medication
for diabetes for blood pressure for
prostate for depression and others and
all these medications have sexual side
effects if you are a man who basically
has focused your entire sexuality around
your penis and your erections and your
ability to get hard and last and have
autonomous spontaneous erections and
suddenly it doesn't happen and you
suddenly think now I have to ask for
help help you know what kind of a man
this is I'm no longer
you know then you give up and the notion
that actually you have an entire body to
make love with and that you spenis
doesn't make the decisions it's a person
who makes decisions for the penis that's
a very different story and that you
actually can experience pleasure in all
kinds of other ways or that you have had
all illnesses with which You' have
grappled with so sex human sexuality is
a very broad topic that evolves in the
course of your life that changes with
your successes with your illnesses with
your children's lives etc etc and that
is one of the best things I can offer to
people is that suddenly the conversation
when you say the person doesn't want to
talk about it it's because what they've
talked about is that narrow why don't
you want to have sex you never want to
have sex all you can think about is sex
that kind of thing and once you've
actually invited them into a whole other
conversation about what is pleasure for
you what is connection what is the
difference between desire and arousal
what does it mean to start because
you're in the mood versus to start
because you're willing I've had Partners
before where I thought you know what if
I laid out the full menu of what I find
pleasurable they would think I was a
weirdo listen I'm not into anything
extreme like I'm not into you know I
have a very look at me apologizing um
I'd think oh they they wouldn't be into
that so I just won't tell them or it
might make them run off off so I won't
tell them and I think dawned on me a
couple of um maybe about a year ago my
girlfriend turned around to me and
actually asked me the question for the
first time about like what my fantasies
were and I was like do I give her the
vanilla menu or do I tell her about the
that's where the card game comes in this
card game mine yes this one I have on
the floor it has a I have a whole bunch
of sexuality related questions and
because you're
playing you
know it's the triangles are the sex ones
but in play mode you can ask this
question about fantasy in a way that is
much less directed yeah or loaded loaded
you know confrontational yeah you you
and and you know there's 60 cards on
that subject alone and that creates a
very different kind of conversation and
I I really think that to put it in the
context of play and playfulness
invites a very different kind of
Revelation and
honesty are you looking yeah I mean this
one says my guilty pleasure is MH give
me the stack I I'll get
you quick one I discovered a product
which has changed my life called ate
sleep and they are now a podcast sponsor
you guys have probably figured out by
now that I'm pretty obsessed with
optimizing my health and specifically my
sleep and I think my sleep has been a
bit of a personal Revelation for me the
importance of it and how much it
correlates to how I feel every day how
creative I am my mood and everything
that seems to matter to me what are the
controllables to have better sleep is
temperature if the room's too hot you
won't sleep your body needs a certain
temperature to sleep but not only that
it needs that temperature to kind of
fluctuate through the night starting
cool getting colder and then heating up
again which is a reflection of Nature
and how our ancestors would have lived
before Central Heating and duvet and air
conditioning and all this stuff highly
recommend at sleep I've spoken to the
founder I understand their mission I
believe in it they're good people this
is one of those products where once
you've tried it you never go back go to
eight sleep.com for exclusive holiday
savings and ring in the most wonderful
time of night eight sleep currently
ships within the UK USA Canada and
select countries in the EU and Australia
as you'll know this podcast is sponsored
by
H and I have to say it's moments like
this in my life where I'm extremely busy
and I'm flying all over the place and
I'm recording TV shows and I'm recording
shows in America and here in the UK that
hu is a necessity in my life I'm someone
that regardless of external
circumstances or professional demands
wants to stay healthy and nutritionally
complete and that's exactly where heel
fits in my life so if you're looking to
try heel for the first time and to get
into it and to join the huigan family
I'd highly recommend you try this out
the most sensual sexual experience I've
had without having sex oh that's a good
one that's a beautiful
one it' probably be being
in the shower with my
partner which is a very vulnerable
experience but it's there's something
quite Central about that experience
absolutely that's the first thing that
came to mind I'll just read a few and
then you can decide you're flaccid at
that point so you're not you know you're
not looking your best you're a little
bit you know and because one of the
early essential experiences that we have
is when our parents or our caregivers
wash us oh okay interesting when they
wash our head when they wash our back
when they rinse off the soap I mean
there are a lot of imprints in the best
of
circumstances of being washed as one of
the most initial pleasurable sensual
without it being sexual at all little
kids you sit in the tub and somebody
puts the water over you and rinses you a
lie I've told about my sex life a
fantasy of mine I'm conflicted about
I've got a couple I'll never forget the
time I was seduced
by you say that in chapter six you say
ask
um a a lot of your work has to do with
people who have shame and anxiety around
sex as people withdraw from a lover as
they fear being judged or rejected by
what they're sort of sexual fantasies
are that's a piece but shame and anxiety
is because a lot of people look if it's
one in four women and one in six men
have experiences of unwanted sex or
abuse or
violation or assault as a lot of people
carrying a lot of very negative
experiences traumatic experiences around
sex it's let's start with that for a
minute so we don't go in la la land so
people carry a lot of Shame a lot of
guilt around this whole dimension of
their being and then it's a subject that
we often are trained to be silent
about and that means that suddenly now
as an adult we have to be able to
communicate about this out of where I
did a thing when I was in London
recently and I'm doing this I'm going to
ask this question again when I go back
on tour it's extremely powerful I ask
people to please let me know if
sexuality was Central in their
family growing up and of course the vast
majority of people say no it wasn't why
because we never talked about it I never
saw my parents being close with each
other or affectionate with each other
and then you begin and you say but if
sex was hidden or up fiscated or
minimized or only hinted at with dirty
jokes does that make it absent or does
that make it more
Central and if sex was violated or
misused or abused does that make it more
peripheral or does that make it more
Central and if there was infidelity in
your family does that make sex absent or
does that make it more in the end you
have 90% of people telling you sex was
Central in my life growing
up and 10% saying no it wasn't it flips
the whole
thing and from there you begin to have
conversations about sexuality you don't
plunge into the
sexlessness you know you ask people how
do you avoid each other what's the dance
here one of you goes to sleep two hours
before the other you make sure you
pretend you're asleep you know what what
is how have you develop this whole
avoidance thing or one person wants one
person doesn't want one person counts
the days that I've just read an episode
recently and literally he would have
wanted sex every day and she is just out
besides herself and and then it becomes
clear that the part of it is because he
needs help to go to sleep but he doesn't
need her necessarily he can also take
care of himself if he wants and that he
would have a much more willing partner
if she wasn't just you know an
alleviation for him and basically they
have a system she counts she knows two
days is okay by the third day it's not
and so she braces herself and so she
just gets through it and you think ah
this is really not a good
situation uh and they have fantastic
relationships and they tell me this is
the only thing that's been an issue
between us now they have had four
children so he waited patiently and he
taught once the kids are a little older
they're going to resume and and they
have not re and she's not at all
interested in resuming to
that and he is so rejected but he has no
concept of how much pressure he puts on
you and she does not necessarily
understand how much he would love for
her to enjoy it and to to experience
some of what he loves to experience and
she has no connection that it's a very
powerful episode coming up it it it
gives you you know they are not sexless
but in some way I could say you know
having sex doesn't make you sex not
sexless I took all the most replayed
moments from some of the interviews
you'd done and I looked at those moments
so I went through all the YouTube
interviews you've done and there's
basically the spikes in conversation are
the parts that people replayed over and
over again and I've got them all written
here wow like what and give them to
after people are so compelled when I
tell them that we do that the first one
was about
cheating but specifically this idea that
even people in open relationships cheat
as we can't resist what is forbidden the
situation you were describing there
seems stereotypically like a situation
where the the man would then go on to
cheat because his needs aren't being met
why do people
cheat I mean I because we we tend to
think it's because one person isn't
getting what they want or because one
person's a bad person or look people
cheat for host of reasons some of them
have to do with the
relationship a loneliness is probably
the biggest
one and wa I was gon to say oh the
variance between men and women when they
cheat ah all right so the first one is
why do people cheat second one is is
there a difference between infidelity in
men and in women so um let's go let's
start with the first thing okay
um I mean I put much of this in the
State of Affairs in the book Because I
had spent 10 years studying Affairs and
infidelity so when you ask me how many
couples it's a lot of
couples and um and I really thought this
experience is so shattering in so many
relationships there must be another way
to understand it it is more complicated
than and there's so much suffering
around it I want to really delve into
this deeper so
people cheat because they're lonely they
cheat because they have been sexually
frustrated for so many years they cheat
because they are resentful they cheat
for vengeance and vindictiveness they
cheat because they
um need to constantly be affirmed by
anybody that can make them feel better
about themselves they cheat for a host
of reasons that have to do with conflict
and discontent and disconnection in
their relationship but they also
sometimes have affairs that have nothing
to do with the
relationship and that's what was one of
the big discoveries for me in the book
which was that sometimes that Affairs
happen in happy couples too
and that sometimes it's not that you
want to leave the person that you are
with as much as you want to leave the
person that you have yourself
become and that it's not that you want
to meet another person as much as you
want to meet another self or other parts
of yourself that have disappeared in
your
life and that at the heart of Affairs
you find betrayal and duplicity and
lying and cheating but at a heart part
of Affairs you also find
longing and loss and yearning and the
word that I heard the most and this
brings us right back to the beginning of
our conversation all over the world I've
gone to 22 countries on this
one is that when people would describe
their Affairs they would say how they
they talk I'm not talking about paid sex
every night sex I'm talking about
Affairs and you know in a more
meaningful sense but people really
talked about the fact that they felt
alive so Affairs are erotic plots
they're they're not just about sex
actually they're about feeling
alive and reconnecting with a some with
an essence of something for many people
but there are many different stories
around Affairs for most of History men
have basically had a practically had a
licens to cheat and it was explained
that they are more nomadic and rors and
conquistador doors and that they are
more quickly bored and they are in need
of novelty I mean basically we gave them
all kinds of justifications to explain
you know and to rationalize why it
happens to them and not to women when in
fact it didn't happen to women because
the consequences were far more dire on
women than on men so we said that when
women cheat it's because they are lonely
and they are in need for intimacy and
you know we all of these stories have
been kind of Rewritten from by now the
biological consequences of a woman
cheating where she would get pregnant
back in the that's one she'd get
destitute yeah she'd lose her
children she had I mean come on we
talking till the 70s women didn't have
access to their own bank accounts on
what was she going to survive she would
be walking with a Scarlet Letter she I
mean everything you want so the
consequences on women women have not
necessarily had different aspirations or
fantasies than men but the women have
done what makes them safe more than what
they would actually what makes them feel
good I felt like I was alive yeah you
hear that from people who have cheated
on their partner does that then infer
that one of the causes of cheating is
that it felt like the relationship or us
as a three me her me him and the
relationship were dead
or yes dead yes an affair is often exper
as an antidote to that kind of deadness
yes but of course my next sentence would
be if people were to put 10% of the
creative imagination that they put into
their Affairs into their marriages or
primary
relationships those relationships would
be doing so much better they put the
planning in the the planning the
attention the creativity the messages
the the hundred texts the flowers the
the the I mean the whole thing the
production you know if people were
bringing that full self so to speak that
creative imaginative effervescent self
that they bring to their lovers to their
relationships their relationships would
not be agonizing do we need novelty of
course we do and how do we get 40 years
into a relation almost 40 years into
your relationship into your
marriage you give me it l once if you're
trapped you give me you look like you
were trapped
by far not how do you keep the novelty
40 years in doing new things
together if you do this is the research
of Eli fle in the All or Nothing
marriage is that if you do the things
that you enjoy but habitually we like to
go to this Cafe to this mountain this
hike this restaurant this beach you know
that that breeds a lot of friendship and
warmth and satisfaction but if you want
to experience
desire it
is wanting something that you don't yet
have it's exploring something that you
don't yet know and that means that
couples who do new things together that
involve an element of risk not because
it's dangerous new things together could
be a conversation that they've never had
new things could be going to a
hotel something outside of the ordinary
you know that you don't do anymore when
you are to together for 40 years or 20
years whatever it is it's that that the
the Regeneration of new cells putting
yourself into situations where you are
not predictable to each other and so you
look Suddenly at each other and you like
what was that like for you and what does
that like for you and this we know is
one of the elements that creates
aliveness in relationships I mean that
that is the distinction now not
everybody wants that and that's okay too
is there a part of when you've been
cheated on that you suddenly value your
partner more I say that because it it
highlights that someone else was
attracted to them and then presumably
you're kind of seeing them through not
as like Dave who just comes home and
just lays V like horizontal that is one
of the responses there are many
different responses but when you ask
people when do you find most drawn when
I can ask you when do you find yourself
most drawn to your partner not just
sexually attracted but most drawn what
would you say when
I one of the one of the times was when I
went and saw her doing her thing at work
so when I go and see her doing her thing
in the breath work Studio it's like
looking at a completely I guess a new
person in a in some way that's right
that's right and what would be another
one
when other people know how be notice how
beautiful she is right right right so
you've just basically name two out of
the three most important answers I have
heard for decades now about this one
worldwide by the way there's only you
know I most drawn to my partner when I
see my partner in their element oh
interesting passionate about something
competent and it could be on stage on a
horse on a slope whatever it is on a
piano it's when I see my partner as a
separate other person that is already so
familiar but that is yet again somewhat
mysterious somewhat unknown somewhat
Elusive and in that moment when they are
radiant and in their element they don't
need me she's not pursuing you she's
doing her thing and that space between
me and the other is where lies the
erotic
Elon this is the bar non the most
important one the second one is when
people talk about I'm drawn to my
partner when we reunite when we've been
away from each
which is the second one you told me
before when you and the third one is
when I see my partner Through The Eyes
of a
third and that be allows me to see my
partner not just as my partner as Bob
but as a separate person who other
people see things that I no longer pay
so much attention to so can we create
that in our relationships yeah I can go
watch her do her thing in her element I
can create some distance we spend time
apart I travel I do my own thing
whatever and also I don't know I go and
ask guys if my girlfriend's
hot I mean you can do it that way but um
of course she needs to have her breath
work yeah yeah yeah there needs to be
something that you know it can be breath
work it can be what she's done with the
house what she does with with with other
careers or or or with her parents or
with her children it doesn't have to
just be you know how just be ler can't
it just be like a new I have rarely
heard somebody say that and because also
I wasn't talking about I'm attracted to
I asked you when I'm drawn to okay and
that drawn to is a very particular but
this answer when I went and I saw her do
her thing is Baran the number one so
interesting and I I mean and the only
one by the way that is gender specific
is when women say when he plays with the
kids because it is
not you know when a woman plays with the
kids it's called motherly it's not drawn
too and that's the only one that is
gender that is gender different or
specific all the others I I mean I can't
tell you the the breath of different
countries were the same answer there's
something about this thing you know I'm
drawn to is an a it's a movement towards
and that movement towards is because
there is an other and that other means
there's a bridge to cross and that
bridge to cross is that erotic energy
and that's what cheating is yes so can
people experience that in their own
relationship yes but of course it
demands recreating it I mean you know we
are living twice as long not everybody's
going to be married for 60 years am
we're working from home that is recent
but yes that sat over there all day and
is yeah that was a killer for a lot of
people is to see you the whole day doing
doing your thing it's uh it it
strengthened the Friendship for many
people and it lessens the erotic for
many
people you know but I I think that
seeing her do her thing or her saying
that to you or I I I find it a very
beautiful answer because it really says
when I see the other as an other it was
that meeting her for the first time
that's what it felt like the first time
I went to one of her breath work
sessions and I I was just kind of hiding
in the corner I was completely
irrelevant it was like spying and she's
got all of her you know her clients's
there there's 25 of them they're all
hypnotized so none of them even know I'm
there she's doing her thing I'm like who
is this person and who are all these
people and what's this place and it felt
like I was I guess meeting her for the
first time in in a way um it's beautiful
and also they have a different
relationship with her and me as a
partner we become kind of encrusted in a
certain way of being with each other
that's why the opening up in the
Triangular gaze is so important how
others see her allow you to see her
differently again and that is all
generative those are all new
cells I'll read you these most replayed
moments anyway just so you know them and
there's I mean we've got a bigger list
of them but I just pulled off the ones
that I thought were pertinent the things
that all erotic couples do have sexual
privacy for play is crucial have an
erotic space where they abandon their
usual roles responsibilities and desire
don't get together the difference
between men and women cheating um is how
to balance Love and Desire and erotic
is being engaged and giving the best of
yourself to your partner whereas most
people give their best of their s to
their friends their colleagues and give
their Partners the leftovers and then in
our other guest that we had on that
speak about relationships and love the
five most replayed moments from those
conversations were the best techniques
for dating apps in different attachment
theories so attachment theories is very
popular um Paul talked about the
importance of longer engagement periods
in being physically but not sexually
attracted to someone Marissa Pier is
about sexless relationships again and
Tracy Cox who again has been talking
about sex relationships for about 20
years Tracy Cox I know um is what her
most replayed moment was why hot sex
stops after two years in a relationship
and the only way to keep going is by
swapping in Partners constantly and
never finding long-term happiness it's a
myth that you can keep hot sex in a
long-term relationship easily that's
true you can have it on occasion here
and there if you think about it as hot
like that that's true um and that's not
necessarily the goal of many people
either I think you know there are people
for whom this is essential in their life
and it it it's the gate that opens them
up to a lot of other important
experiences in their life and then there
are people for whom this is not nearly
as Central they enjoy it but they they
don't need it to be hot they enjoy
the what is often called maintenance sex
erotic couples have a lot of Maintenance
sex and on occasion they get suddenly
this really unusual hot you know
different wow it's been a while out of
nowhere but they have actually a lot of
of Maintenance and and they do have an
understanding of not just I'm drawn to
this person who is different from me but
also a person who has their own erotic
interiority of them of their own and
they don't and they are okay with that
they're not threatened by it because
because each of them have thoughts and
Fantasies that are not necessarily just
about the relationship of course how do
we
conclude our conversation yeah like how
do we conclude we've talked about
relationships love connection all of
these things in between is there a
through line of advice a conclusion that
would help people maybe something with a
that is actionable maybe something that
feels somewhat easy or simple maybe not
easy so we can go back to the things
that we talked about
together and about you as well I said to
you relationships is an active
engagement it demands uh
risk it demands vulnerability and it
demands accountability which we didn't
talk about as much typically when people
are in trouble they want the other
person to change and to do the work and
I said if you want to change the other
change yourself ask yourself what can I
do that would make it better and do it
and don't begin to say but why me and
but but you know just do your thing
because it's ultimately what you want
because there is such a thing called
enlightened
self-interest do it because it's the
relationship you want the relationship
is the third it's exactly the way you
said it so when you are about to say or
do something ask yourself what will this
do to the relationship if I do this now
or if I say this now or if I don't say
this now and do things not because they
suit you but because they suit the
relationship because ultimately the
relationship is there to serve you but
it's a back and forth Love Is A Verb I
think is a very important thing and that
means you you actively do a bunch of
things I mean it's the same with food
you know some people just are okay
eating whatever is in their fridge and
most of the time there nothing on the
Shelf it's said but some people are
actively searching the right ingredients
they go to this Market to this store
they put it together there's an art art
to that it's an art a relationship and
that art you can bring to your love
relationship as well I think a lot of
people end up in a rut because they're
complacent they're lazy they're
unimaginative and they have a lot of
imagination for a lot of stuff outside
but not with their partner and then they
say I'm bored well then that it didn't
you know do something um and and it's
amazing how hard it is for some people
to do it I one of the things I think is
really interesting imagine instead of
the DMS and stuff you know we just had a
long conversation and this evening when
you go and wherever you stay and you
just basically write a letter and you
write a letter to your partner and just
say you know I had this woman there
today and we talked about all this stuff
and and it made me think it made me
think about the first time when we met
and I told her about being there in the
background watching you do this work and
and I realize that it's been a long time
since I watched you do this work work
and I probably should show up again
because I don't even know what you've
been doing since I don't do the same
thing as 5 years ago or however long you
are together can't imagine that you are
and I realize that you know I expect a
certain kind of coziness but then I'm
thinking oh where is the novelty and I
don't pursue the novelty but there is
novelty I have been doing new things you
must have been doing new things why am I
asking you know is novelty important it
is and it's there but I need to go look
for it and I was talking about the
maintenance sex and I was talking about
the shower and I was talking about so
many moments between us and I just
thought I should share this with you
when people sit down with themselves and
they start to write you know I've been
thinking about us and it's been a long
time since I even said any of these
things I mean man this is like filling
up a tank of
gasoline
why because you say I value this and I
value you and I value what we've created
and we matter and it's important and I
cherish it and I adore it and I and I
sometimes don't pay enough attention to
it and I just take it for granted and
and that is not a good thing to do it's
like food that stays on a shelf for
months on end well it
rots and there's something about
something fresh and it's it be it it
breaks through the
calcification it is a lubricant
in the full sense of the word speaking
of something fresh you have an online
course called Turning conflict into
connection we've talked about connection
we've talked about
conflict why did you make this course
and here is this for this turning
conflict into connection
course it's a one-hour course it's very
short it's eight videos and a fantastic
workbook and it's for people who kind of
say I could we we keep getting into the
same arguments it's for people who say
you know how do we turn this thing
around it's for people who say you know
we're in a rut and and who are willing
to try things without having to go to
therapy necessarily so it gives you a
very clear understanding of what's the
difference between what is it they
fighting about versus what are you
fighting for in terms of what are the
underlying unmet needs what is you know
behind every criticism there's a wish
what is it that you're wishing for
rather than how do you turn what is
called negative sentiment override when
a relationship becomes overly critical
judgmental you know spiral of you know
how do you turn the tone around how do
you remember the fondness for another
person Etc well everyone needs that and
that's why I created it because I think
people are lacking the skills therapy is
not the only place to do it um I think
that we are avoidant in Conflict we
don't have enough of that free play
practice and I thought God the thing
that I hear so much is people who are
not talking to their friend people who
are saying this is too difficult we
shouldn't have and I thought woo before
you throw the whole thing let's see if
you can you know the some of these
things are changeable of course you have
to be accountable if all you want to
tell me is how you are the Saint and the
other is the villain we're not going
anywhere so I thought let me create a
few courses like this I've done the
conflict I've gone one coming out on sex
the things that I've been talking about
that I've written about and I thought
after that or even the thing you listen
to on the podcast but now I want you to
have something where you can actually do
and practice some some things that I
think will help you we have a closing
tradition as you know which is the last
guest leaves a question in this book not
knowing who they're going to be leaving
it for okay and I don't get to see it
until I open the book here we go oh what
is the one piece of advice you received
in the last decade that you think about
most
frequently I think whenever I'm thinking
this way the first person that comes up
for me is my
father who was
illiterate had gone to school for three
years and
who basically would say to me my little
one do not get impressed
by the money by The Fame by the
education look at the
decency and I was a hitchhiker for many
years as a young person I traveled a ton
and that became the thing I took with me
I was taken in by the kindness of
strangers in various circumstances who
knew nothing about who I was who
probably had the most different Pol iCal
opinions from me you could imagine who
had never heard about where Belgium
could be anything they just were
kind decent caring human beings who
shared whatever little they had you know
and sometimes they had no electricity no
nothing they just cooked me an entire
meal with a candle next to them and I
think that that has really stayed with
me it's it it's look at the decency of
the person and don't get
impressed by the acutance and the status
symbols and all of that um and I really
thank him for that it it gives you
Clarity it keeps you very
grounded um I love the message and I've
actually passed the message on to my own
kids as well Esther thank you so much
it's a pleasure thank you for your
Brilliance and um everyone has been
hammering me for many a year on all of
my social media channels in my team in
London here all over to have this
conversation with you and you exceed all
expectations every single time you're
just uh you're such an incredible human
being that um that I'm so I'm so glad
exists because there's something so
special about you that I as I said it's
like you can't replicate that it's
Brilliance thank you so thank you so
much it's been a pleasure to meet you I
mean it with every word of every fiber
in my body so thank you Esther thank you
very
[Music]
much as you guys know I'm an investor in
a company called Zoe and also they
sponsor this podcast and they're one of
my favorite businesses literally of all
time we're in December now which is the
season of gifting the season of family
gatherings and parties but what I'll be
doing this December is making sure I
double down on my health because it's
this time of year where I think it's
easiest to get distracted and derailed
and that is where Zoe comes in for many
years I thought we all had the same
relationship with food and now I know
that every single person has a different
relationship with every single type of
food and knowing the type of food that
you have the best relationship with the
food that loves you back can quite
literally change your life and that's
where a Zoe membership comes in so if
there was ever a time to become a Zoe
member it is right now in December that
rhymes should have been a rapper so do
not wait till the new year to invest in
your health use my discount code ceo1 to
get 10% off your Zoe kit right now and
make sure you keep that code yourself
okay go and use it right
now you need a podcast to listen to next
we've discovered that people who liked
this episode also tend to absolutely
love another recent episode we've done
so I've linked that episode in the
description below I know you'll enjoy
[Music]
it